on Tuesday Donald Trump revealed he will
not be participating in Thursday's
presidential debate ET was with Fox News
host and debate moderator megyn kelly
shortly after Trump made the
announcement she said she's hopeful he
might change his mind I'll be surprised
if he doesn't come I mean I know he says
he doesn't want to now but I'll really
be surprised because I feel like the
people of Iowa are still persuadable and
if he's in a tight race with Ted Cruz I
don't know why he wouldn't take the last
opportunity to make his case to them in
such a huge Kellyanne Trump have a
tumultuous history last August the
presidential hopeful unleashed a series
of verbal attacks against the journalist
after she questioned his previous
statements about women Kelly also told
Vanity Fair's February issue Trump tried
to woo her to gain her support prior to
announcing his candidacy still though if
Trump decides to show up Kelly
insists on doing a fair and neutral
debate I have no conflict and no bias
against Donald Trump and I really do
hope he comes to the debate because I
think he would he would it would behoove
him to stand there and be tested next to
his fellow candidates to come into the
lion's den and answer those tough
questions do it you know stand there
engage do well do better take on the
other guys let's get into it let's have
fun let's have a meaningful substantive
exchange last week Sarah Palin endorsed
Trump for president in a headline making
speech that Kelly seemingly enjoyed
watching it was riveting television it
was riveting who could take her eyes off
of him right she knows how to make a
splash she is a television phenom as is
he so to watch the two of them next to
each other this the dynamic was just
riveting